any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
welcome everyone to this episode of the
into the impossible podcast a
subset of the normal into the
imagination
podcast the playlist if you will we're
calling nobel mines
and it's fitting that the first entry
in our nobel mines podcast series
involves none other than duncan haldane
who was not only a professor at one
point when he did the work
that led to his winning the nobel prize
in 2016.
he was a nobel prize uh aspirant and
worked on the theory that led him to his
nobel prize for
topological matter and phase transitions
while he was a professor at uc san diego
and then
we unfortunately lost him to our bitter
rivals across the country
in princeton university uh just kidding
we're
very friendly with that fair university
which has more than its fair share
of nobel laureates and duncan holdings
are a very interesting guy he came to
uc san diego in 2017 to record this
interview
but i think it's sort of timeless and
evergreen type message
and that we talked about what makes the
process of creativity
especially in the realm of the quantum
where he
inhabits with his colleagues and how
that is so mysterious
and but yet so captivating and perhaps
so important
so in this episode we discussed the
difficulty in explaining what he calls
quantum weirdness
and the links that people including the
nobel committee went to when they tried
to describe
his work uh along with um with phallus
and
my former professor at brown university
michael kosterlitz
uh when they won the nobel prize the
committee had to hold up you know a set
of bagels and pretzels and other kinds
of weird
buns and so forth uh that duncan talked
about during the lecture
uh that appreciated this particular
interview uh what's remarkable about him
is
he's he's uh he's very mischievous and
intellectually
curious way he has this really devilish
delightful
ability to be playful and also
humble and mindful of his place in
history
he actually plays a not small role in my
book losing the nobel prize he's
actually featured
in the book there's a picture of him in
the book and we'll fold in a picture in
the background
but he did in fact come to ucsd
with a real live
nobel prize back in 2017
when he was um we were hosting him here
on campus and he had returned for the
first time perhaps in decades
and i remarked as i do in the book that
he brought with him this prize and
afterwards people were
mobbing him and coming up to him and
asking uh for pictures not with him but
with his nobel prize
and i'm holding it up and i say um and
the author is holding
the last nobel prize he may ever hold me
it was the end of my
hopes and actually he came to ucsd as i
was finishing up the first draft of my
book
of losing the nobel prize and uh and i
even i succumbed to this desire
to want to bask in the glory of holding
this gilded graven image
shown behind me if you're watching the
video uh so
uh he's a delightful person i always say
uh
you know i don't have any fault against
the nobel prize winners
because the one rule that they uh
provided when i was
asked to select the winners of the 2016
prize spoiler alert i did not choose
duncan
um but uh but other people but
nevertheless the one rule that they
still adhere to and alfred nobel's
will has largely gone out the window
with the ways that they've modified it
as i described in the book
uh they they adhere to it basically in
two ways they
still want it to benefit mankind and
they also
say that you can't choose yourself you
cannot literally cannot nominate
yourself during the nobel prize so
um for those reasons i think duncan's a
very special person
um and he he and i speak in this episode
as you're about to hear
uh see about well the value of basic
scientific research what he's doing
and whether or not it has a direct
benefit to mankind as alfred nobel
stipulated in his will
and and he makes a remark in the video
that you'll see
that you know just as maxwell could not
have predicted
the import and impact of his equations
and could not have foreseen that they
would be
describing how an iphone works so too
with a strange topological matter
that they've uh or rewarded the nobel
prize for
so too we may never know what the impact
and import of that
discovery will be and so uh he really
makes the case in this episode that the
the true arbiter of truth
really comes down to that experimental
verification which is music to my ears
as an experimental
cosmologist but that that was really
when
the magnitude of his discovery truly hit
him
and so it's a fascinating glimpse into
the mind a nobel mind as we call them
uh on this playlist and i hope you'll
enjoy it and i hope you'll
leave some comments uh in the uh in the
box below
thank you uh and i thought we'd just
start with a very brief introduction for
our listeners as to
uh the the occasion or the the
accomplishment for which you're awarded
the nobel prize i'll just read the
citation you won your nobel prize for
your work in condensed matter physics
and you shared it with
michael kosterlitz who was my professor
at brown university a long time ago
and david thalis for theoretical
discoveries of topological phase
transitions and topological phases of
matter
especially in quantum systems confined
to two-dimensional surfaces so
this is not something that's you know on
the tip of everybody's tongue uh
is there any possible way we've seen the
contortions that the noble committee
went to to try to explain
your work i wonder is that fundamentally
irreducible as feynman said if i could
explain it to you it wouldn't be worth a
nobel prize
uh or can can one actually explain it in
a way that's com
as comprehensible as possible
well i don't know i mean thanks brian uh
i i have a
quote which maybe a misquote from
feynman which says that if you can't
explain the
um the pali exclusion principle
or the spin statistic theorem to your
grandmother you don't understand it
properly
she went to say he did we don't so i
don't know i mean
the the quantum mechanics is this
mysterious thing
that uh physicists get by by
by just taking it taking it for granted
and not worrying about it while the
philosophers and the general public kind
of spend find it incomprehensible but
it seems to be the way the the universe
works that seems to weigh the way the
world works and um
the only way i've really come up come up
with ex explaining these things is that
quantum mechanics can do really cooler
things than we thought possible
and uh so that's part of the excitement
this this whole topological physics has
been
incredibly inspiring to and uh to young
people in fact you've got a whole lot of
young people very interested in in
physics it's
because somehow a very powerful and
clean idea like
topology from mathematics turned out to
allow one to to think about uh very
constructively
about these properties of quantum
mechanics and until this happened
topology was just not there in quantum
mechanics
let's take this piece by piece what is
topology
topology is a branch of mathematics
concerned with how properties of objects
are preserved when they are stretched
deformed
or twisted a circle is topologically the
same
as an oval for example it's a stretched
circle
but all the possible positions of a hand
on a clock
are also equivalent to a circle
according to a topologist
mathematically topology is really really
good at describing three-dimensional
surfaces
and haldane with the others he shared
the nobel with pioneered some really
hard math that worked really well
when used to understand unusual phases
or states of matter beyond the common
three
the common three being gas liquid or
solid
at really low temperatures weird states
occur
like superconductivity that's when an
electrical current can pass through an
ultra cooled material with
zero resistance that shift from plane
matter
to superconductive matter and similar
changes in state like
superfluids is something haldane's work
has been able to explain
and by being able to explain it it has
allowed scientists
to begin to develop new materials that
exhibit and exploit these properties
perhaps even paving the way for things
as far out there
as quantum computers something haldane
himself used to consider
a pure science fiction fantasy it seems
to me that your discovery
with your with your colleagues you know
part of it
it really uh made physical a very
abstract notion of topology
which is you know sort of the
connectedness and you show these
beautiful uh uh images of
you know pretzels and of coffee cups and
donuts and things like that made me very
hungry
uh but but in addition
these are these are purely mathematical
concepts which you reduce to a physical
entity to a notion
that really is you know i always say to
my students i can't hand you a triangle
i can only hand you the notes during the
nobel prize ceremony the presenter held
up
a bagel a pretzel and a cinnamon bun and
not because he wanted to highlight the
variety of offerings at your local mall
topology describes objects with set
number of
holes and these are the only things a
topologist
really cares about the number of holes
the bagel has one
the pretzel has two and a cinnamon bun
is holeless unless you pop out that rich
gooey part in the middle
the differences between the objects
cinnamon pecans flower composition
savory or sweet are not important but
when a material switches between
state to become a superconductor it's
like
a bagel turning into a bun there's a
famous joke about this
so it starts uh what is a topologist and
the answer is
someone who cannot distinguish between a
donut and a coffee cup
get it each one only has one hole
as you might guess quantum physics night
at the comedy cellar is a little bit
complicated
you know jokes are seen in light of
schrodinger's cat and they
simultaneously kill and do not kill the
atmosphere gets
very very uncertain for haldane the 2016
nobel
began back in the 1980s and involved a
chain reaction of hints
discoveries and new applications
distributed between various colleagues
and universities i think everything has
really come together through no one
individual
but but generally a recognition
something new showing up and then when
something new shows up it takes a bit of
time to put it in
context all this stuff the new things
that
showed up and it turned out two things i
contributed i wouldn't have said they
were connected in
the obvious way i didn't know the
connection and it
only later with work of shagan wen
who who set up a a
systematic classification of of
topological states and it turns out the
magnetic atom thing is in some sense the
hydrogen atom the simplest example of a
of a topological
state of matter you created much of the
the work that that led to the nobel
prize 30 40 years ago and yet and and i
remember hearing about it not just from
my you know my statement professor
michael coster that's but but i do
remember
you know hearing uh whispers that that
you guys were going to win the nobel
prize and it was sort of a foregone
conclusion
uh you know a what you know no i don't
think it was a foregone conclusion i
think
this stuff was very interesting to
theorists
it was a lot of you know it was
controversial
and people were theorists were
interested but i think what really
made this uh prize possible was the
the actual development probably by
uh charlie kane and really that they
they took
they they pushed my work in a way that i
hadn't
i mean i actually thought of pushing it
in that direction too but i never
actually
i took a view that i didn't actually do
the calculation i thought about
exactly the same generalization and uh
but then i thought
once you make it realistic it won't work
and the amazing thing which actually
charlie kane told me that they tested by
doing a calculation i assumed what the
calculation would be
in advance of doing it and never did it
so i assumed there was no point in doing
it because it wouldn't work
charlie so say they anyway they didn't
think
they see why it would work but they put
it on a computer and checked it out and
they found there was a new principle of
uh
involving um fermion parity which was
not obvious
and that led and the fermion parity and
very topological invariant led to the
three-dimensional
case and once again it took work by
others like uh
andrey bernabek and shuchen zhang were
kind of looking at this stuff
and the original models were again very
not not very practical and they didn't
work
out for graphene but these things
require three
three levels of things to come together
one is i think that
there's some deep underlying and
abstract principles which
are there to be found but they're very
difficult to understand and work with
i think the toy model intermediary that
you can actually do a calculation
fully see all the bits how it all fits
together
and maybe see something unexpected that
need never unders
why that works is it shouldn't really
have worked but it did
to see that and then finally the third
piece is for someone to actually make a
connection to to physical materials
and then the thing takes off you
actually to make a success you need
these
you need the underlying fundamental but
probably difficult and abstract stuff
which might be the mathematics in this
case
the principles the concrete calculation
that really shows it up and then
someone finding out how you actually
make a real material of course once
real materials were found then everyone
was excited and
starting to search for them and
experimentalists all
experimentalists were showing movies of
coffee cups changing into donuts and
back again
the nobel prize was originally framed as
honoring science that provides the
greatest benefit
to mankind when it's so hard for us
humankind to understand the research
that was honored by the prize
knowing where that benefit to humanity
is can be difficult to see
which isn't to say it's not there how
how do you see this creative process
leading to the beneficence that alfred
nobel envisioned to mankind
well i think the
the deepening of the understanding of of
nature especially
quantum mechanics is uh is the seed corn
for all kinds of the future development
of technology and i think this century i
used to be
you know skeptical and think you know
that quantum computers were snake oil
salesmen or
psycho but uh the seeing how
when people start to to actually
get serious about looking at things how
much the improvements of the
you know the how long how long coherence
can be maintained and how these
things improve and just the
effect of of people getting excited
about something and working on it and
how much should advance i think
we will see some kind of uh
quantum information technology of some
kind emerging may not be
you know breaking all our credit card
codes
i'm not sure what it will be if what
form it will take and
you know be difficult to predict what
you know
you know maxwell wouldn't have predicted
iphones right
so so i think i underst
getting better and understanding of of
the fundamental principles of
how the world works is absolutely uh
benefit to mankind
and it will actually historically it's
always led
to uh to useful things that benefit
the man in the streets and the woman in
the street too right i mean it's a very
uh
it's a good it's i wouldn't bet against
it
very well when we say it's difficult to
see
the benefit of research like this we use
seeing as a metaphor for knowing
a pretty common metaphor and seeing is
so integral to our ways of knowing going
back into
prehistory arguably more so than hearing
touching tasting or smelling very
arguably but still
it's why the nobel committee swung by
the bakery before their award
ceremony to pick up a bagel pretzel and
bun
quantum physics and cosmology present
special challenges for seeing what these
theories propose
and for knowing what they represent
these are the things which are the
furthest away from our everyday
experience on this human scale
either on the very small or they're very
large or
they all they're all weird and so of
course we can't
immediately you know get understand them
by just looking around us we of course
need to look around this in very special
ways for cosmology and for quantum
mechanics
um with uh but yeah so obviously
if we're just kind of you know monkeys
or something over here and they would be
interested in bananas or whatever it is
but
these things are way beyond the issues
of
getting in every day getting enough
bananas
any sufficiently advanced technology is
indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
if you enjoyed this episode of into the
impossible please subscribe
comment share rate and review for a
chance to win a free copy of our most
recent guest's newest book
send a screenshot of your review to info
imagine.ucsd.edu
we appreciate hearing from you and are
always open to your suggestions for
future episodes
for more information go to
imagination.ucsd.edu
find us on twitter at imagineucsd
watch us on youtube listen on itunes
into the impossible is a production of
the arthur c clarke center for human
imagination in the division of physical
sciences
at the university of california san
diego
eric very director brian keating
co-director
patrick coleman associate director
produced by
stuart valco